l'entretien politique avec pierre
morange maire de chambourcy bonjour
bonjour scanner chambourcy
voilà c'est une ville d'environ 6000
habitants ou pas très loin de saint
germain en laye et de et de poissy
membres de la communauté d'agglomération
saint germain boucles de seine d'où vous
êtes d'ailleurs le vice président c'est
une ville plutôt jeunes puisque j'ai
appris la proportion des décors
mauricien puisqu'on des appels comme ça
est plutôt de moins de 60 ans et plus
tôt plus élevé que dans le reste du
département et puis elle est célèbre
aussi cette commune pour le fantastique
désert de red que j'avais eu le plaisir
de visiter avec vous mais aussi la
maison d'andré derain et puis les
vestiges de la bêtise de l'abbaye de
joyon va alors vous avez été réélu maire
brillamment dès le premier tour des
dernières élections
la première phrase que vous avez été élu
c'était en 1995
alors on dit souvent que les maires sont
les seuls les bus qui voit au fond des
changements qu'ils font dans leur ville
qu'est ce qui s'est passé à chambourcy
depuis 25 ans c'est à dire depuis votre
premier mandat qu'est ce qui a changé
eh bien il ya plusieurs éléments qui ont
amélioré le quotidien on fait des camps
boétiens je suis devenu maire de la
commune de rembourser mon obsession a
été tout simplement de la libérer des
embouteillages dans lesquelles elle
était en bus dans l'embouteillage
national très devenue départementale
d'ordre 113 depuis était légendaire il
fallait compter à peu près 20 à 30
minutes pour traverser une commune de
6000 habitants soient sentis simplement
parce que de chants boursiers occupe un
endroit géo stratégiques définis au
ténor à la forêt de symboles et au sud
par la forêt de mal donc en pratique
bublé appareil où ils repartirent la
normandie vous devez passer par
chambourcy est donc un effet d'entonnoir
qui en conditionne finalement les
astreintes
j'ai fait en sorte de double et
l'ensemble de ces voiries j'ai fait
installer construire un échangeur
complet par les provinces qui nous met à
12 minutes de la défense premier
quartier d'affaires d'europe et donc
faisant de ce fait d'heureux donnant une
attractivité à nulle autre pareille
parallèlement j'ai fait en sorte de
rénover renforcer l'ensemble des
équipements commerciaux qui sont trop
conséquent à chambourcy
mais tout en étant dans une le cadre
d'une évolution maîtrisée qui n'avait
pas vocation à être des centres
commerciaux grandes marques comme on
peut le voir dans certaines
agglomérations
enfin en complétant l'ensemble de ses
demandes
grâce aux moyens issus la fiscalité
économique en renforçant les équipes en
scolaire jeux sportifs en acquérant bien
yvan vous le savez vous avez la gentille
je le rappelais des éléments
patrimoniaux le désert de retz cela mais
centre et de rats et bien d'autres et en
faisant d'autres travaux comme maison de
santé
enfin bref l'ensemble du quotidien de
tous maires de france et de navarre
alors vous parliez de la défense qui
était proche finalement de deux chambres
si les habitants de chambourcy les
coloris siens ce sont plutôt des gens
qui travaillent sur place où des gens
qui travaillent dont réjean parent à
paris ou dans d'autres
nous en droit des yvelines par exemple
eh bien en fait l'ex parisien qui sont
ce qu'on appelle classiquement des
rurbains c'est à dire ce sont des
urbains qui sont installés en fait dans
un environnement naturel qui est assez
agréable tout en étant proximité des
deux grandes villes de proximité que
j'évoquais ou des lots qui vous même
c'est à dire ça j'ai avalé poissy et à
douze minutes de ce fameux quartier
d'affaires donc de la défense le comte
et quand ce qu'elle était c'est que nous
700 entreprises sur le territoire
cambodgien plus 540 millions d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires annuel
nous avons un bassin d'emploi de plus de
4000 postes de travail pour une
population active de 2300 c'est dire que
c'est la commission exceptionnelle de
concentration le moyenne départementale
et au tourne autour des 08 09 nous nous
sommes à 1,7
sic aussi là l'offre de travail il est
assez spécialisés dans le domaine du
commerce et donc des services
dématérialisés nous avons un des
premiers spécialistes en matière de
médiamétrie quant à l'ancien secodip et
qui est installée dans nos murs d'où en
fait une proximité mais aussi une un
taux de migration pour les combos essien
de 33% travail sur la commune et les
deux tiers parts sur paris intra muros
où la petite couronne d'accord alors
vous êtes médecin vous avez deux tops et
msa il ya évidemment cette crise
pendant près de vingt ans maintenant le
vrai battant absolument et il ya cette
crise sanitaire qui affecte la france on
a vu que les mères étaient souvent en
première ligne dans le combat entre la
coved comment ça se passe c'est vous ça
se passe de façon tout à fait très
pragmatique l'avantagé de ces
collectivités qui sont de taille tout à
fait raisonnable que je qualifierais de
familiale affaissé lite la proximité et
la convivialité la perception des
besoins au quotidien
au delà de toutes les procédures à
l'instar sous prescription donc des
directives du gouvernement en sont
légères sur barrière
les gels hydro alcooliques les masques
ne constituent des stocks nous l'ont
fait en sorte que chaque camp mauricien
et gratuitement deux masques avec la
capacité à les renouveler tous les deux
mois 6 av
nous avons mis en place toute une série
d'autres dispositifs des rondes
achetez des détecteurs thermiques pour
chaque site public afin d'être dans une
logique globale de prévention est aussi
une seule capacité à fournir des
prestations et des services pour celles
et ceux qui est dans la situation de
fragilité de solidarité que tant sur le
plan social que physique et aux
personnes à mobilité réduite
tous les fonctionnaires donc ne les
communes sont mises à la disposition des
camps mauricienne pour aller faire leurs
courses
très concrètement et il n'y avait que je
peux voir classer un coup de tête en
mairie de chambourcy et vous avez
immédiatement une équipe j'ai moi même
participé pour apporter ses courses ou
la commune était caution de l'achat
auprès de la grande surface qui se
trouvent sur notre commune une dernière
question peut-être pour beaucoup plus
vous avez été vous avez occupé d'autres
fonctions politiques vous avez été
notamment de député des yvelines
est ce que vous direz que la fonction de
maire au fond c'est celle que vous
préférez absolument c'est tout à fait
passionnant je peux lire une bonne chose
j'ai été comme je voulais évoqué médecin
pendant près de 20 ans je suis maire
depuis plus d'un quart de siècle
j'étais représente la nation pendant
près de 20 ans alors quand je vois le
spectacle donc de ce parlement que j'ai
beaucoup aimé mais qui finalement n'est
plus que l'ombre de lui même temps la
concentration pouvoir est détenu entre
les mains de quelques dizaines de
technocrates jeux sont profonds que tu
as les français se trouve bien plus tu
as fait évidemment situer au niveau lui
avec une capacité à répondre à leur
demande et pour laquelle finalement le
plus beau verbe notre langue française
c'est servir et non pas se servir et
self à cette compétition où j'ai le
sentiment que pour l'ancien
parlementaire je puis je me permets de
vous plaît à parlementaire ça représente
le peuple français
deuxièmement ça laisse faire on légifère
trouve et troisièmement il faut
contrôler l'exécutif du gouvernement ce
qui malheureusement le cas et qui
aboutit à nos respects des efforts des
français au travers des impôts qu'il
verse à la collectivité
merci infiniment pierre morange maire
d'honfleur précis il ya très vite pour
voilà d'une nouvelle rencontre l'espère
et pour visiter profondément la ville de
chambourcy très merci à vous et très
bonne journée